yo it's code of the friend check me out
on the bootleg kev podcast
boom boo lay cat podcast special guest
in here we got a new floating foot
from odd socks i'm not sure how long
this is going to last because it's kind
of impractical and a pain in the ass
but there is a floating foot from our
great sponsors at odd socks there's a
godfather sock on there in case you're
into the movie
fight i love godfather me too
what's the best godfather movie
certainly not three it's not it wasn't
it wasn't three it wasn't three it's one
i love one and two you know
like equally yeah listen coder the
friend is here welcome man what's up
welcome i feel like it's been a [ __ ] i
don't even know the last time you came
on the show it was like when i was at
the radio station and
i don't even know how long ago was like
2018 or 19 i think 2018. long ass time
ago you've definitely glowed up since
then
things have been going very very well
for you
but yeah what's been going on man
i just been working working on a new
album i'm always working on music you
know so i'm just i saw on twitter you
said you can't wait to turn this album
in yeah yeah so does that mean are you
are you like what's your label situation
now because things have changed since we
first
kind of came in contact with you like
you're very much
doing your thing like i said are you
signed now or
no i'm still independent like um
i work with a company called venice oh
shout out to venice they do uh tweeze
music yeah shout out to venice the
really dope company distro
and they distribute my music and i get
to put it out whenever i want that's a
beautiful thing that's a beautiful thing
man um when do you feel like things
started to like really cause like what i
always loved about like
your videos and your content
was it was always so simple but like the
way you would do like your lyrics to go
videos with the yellow font
and
it just to me was like
a very
dope way to
not really have any because you know
people always think they got to put up
this outlandish video content
and it's like you really don't need to
do that you really just got to do like
something that looks good
aesthetically pleasing and you were
putting up a lot of those videos like i
feel like that's kind of like you've
been doing that for a minute you're
still doing it yeah i'm still doing it
um
it was honestly it came i did it because
i didn't have any money to get any real
videos done and like i have a background
in like video production right and
editing so i was like yo this is a good
way to just get my face out there at
least while i don't have any resources
and um
it turned out like it went viral like
the first one i did it was like it went
more viral than anything i'd ever done
so i was just like [ __ ] why don't i just
keep on you shooting on your iphone no i
shoot on the cameras um
it's the same camera camera for the past
like four years it's a panasonic gh5
shout out to the gh5 gh5 is a hell of a
camera yeah especially get the right
lens on that thing
shoot any video on that i put the l
series the canon l series on that joint
and we just we just go do you like um
like outside of the those videos like do
you have a lot like when you even when
you bring in like an outside director do
you still have a lot of say like kind of
in individuals
well since you kind of have background
in that
yeah i've never done i've never had um
outside director you're um
like videographer everything's in-house
everything's in-house but um i plan on
like getting somebody to do my videos at
some point you know do you have like a
guy you use or you just it's all you
it's all me you edit so you edit your
own videos yeah i did my own videos
that's fire thank you bro what all in
the creative process do you handle
yourself
um everywhere like as far as uh i
produce my own stuff um i write
obviously i record myself
uh the only thing i don't do is mix i
like i'm not an engineer i can't i can't
i can mix well enough only so you can
hear it and be like oh this is cool but
like i never like what people here on
the record is not me makes it so you
make the beats you record yourself you
write
you're doing the videos are you doing
the artwork
yeah i do the artwork a lot of times wow
that's pretty big man also it keeps a
lot of money in your pockets yeah but
it's fun for me like i think um i just
like creating stuff so
it's nothing for me to do all this stuff
because i have fun doing it you know
like even when i feel like soon i'm
gonna step away from rap to do some
other cool [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's just like i just want to make cool
[ __ ] like what if let's say you step
away from rap in two years what is what
what do you want to do
uh i want to like see my friends win you
know so it's like i want to build their
careers and it's like because that's how
fun it is for me just to do stuff and to
see it work
so i just uh really want to focus on
supporting the people around me and
seeing what they can do with their you
know with their talents do you feel like
you
have like
a lot of just because you've done a good
job of developing like a core fan base
like you said like putting out content
do you feel like you kind of have like a
bit of a formula down
that other artist can apply to what
they're doing yeah i thought i did you
know right then
[ __ ] changes you know [ __ ] that's
changing like crazy like the social
media landscape like
instagram was a big thing for me and
like how i came up and it's completely
changing
yeah it's tick tocks and like now i'm
like i'm oh i'm gonna oh i'm the old man
now so it's just like i'm trying to
catch up so honestly i'm watching
younger artists and younger indie
artists and seeing how they do it and
i'm like you know no it's definitely
different like with like the duets like
i've been noticing so many producers
coming up with that well they'll do the
beats and then like have hella tick tock
rappers rap over there like uh shout out
to kato kato right right blowing up he
killed that [ __ ] and he's always been
that dude but like
tick tock put him on another level shout
out to dude man i've seen it you see him
everywhere knows 100 um let's get to
like kind of some of your roots man like
uh you're from new york right yes sir
what borough are you from brooklyn shout
out to brooklyn um
when like did you finally
decide like rapping was kind of what you
wanted to do like maybe not necessarily
like
getting money off of it but you just
kind of said okay this is kind of where
like how old were you when when you
decided that that was kind of like where
you wanted to go
yeah i think um
it was pretty much just like a hobby
until
like my son my son was about to be born
and i was just like i really gotta pick
something you know it's like
everything was a hobby i was making
videos i was um i was rapping but
obviously i wasn't making money off of
rap but um you know i had a choice to
make it was like either i'm gonna do
this video thing or i'm gonna i'm gonna
make this this music should work and so
i was just like yo i'm gonna just do
this you know i'm gonna just make music
because i love it and um it was the
funnest thing to do and so i was like
it's pretty funny i mean yeah you're
about to have a kid so that's a pretty
uh
that's a pretty brave thing to step like
you had were you did you have a normal
job at the time uh i was shooting videos
so you were just shoot you were the
video guy yeah i was the video guy
that's crazy
i mean i mean it's a nice skill to have
if you're going to be an artist yeah
that's one of the more expensive uh
costs that artists have
shooting videos when did you start
writing originally like was it in high
school was it earlier like when did you
first start kind of just starting
writing and developing your craft
well i started writing when i was like
probably like eight or something like
that like i was a kid and we just
obviously we watching bt watching the
106 countdown of course and
we're just like yo we want to be i want
to be jay-z i want to be this so we
would me and my cousins would all get
together at the table at my grandma's
table and we just write raps you know
yeah like and we record on like a little
like tape recorder
and so that's when i that would honestly
i wrote raps like i wrote full raps to
like jay-z instrumentals like
as a kid so where were you getting jay-z
instrumentals at um
limewire shout out to limewire
you were you were [ __ ] up your
grandma's lap [ __ ] computer nah i had
the i had the um i had the the kind of
the formula to not get the viruses bro
you know what was that formula telling
you bro
it's too late now but now but like i'm
like dude i used to ruin every computer
i had i got you bro what i would do is i
would download the limewire right
download mad songs
like mad songs at once right and then i
would just come you had to completely
remove it off your computer you know
like you know and then i would wait a
couple days and i would put it back on
you know download a bunch of things
i was so i would do that like every
every two days or so because like
because i think the virus part would
come in because you're everyone was
leeching off your files right yeah but i
feel like that's why you can't let it
sit on your computer you know what i
mean
like if i feel like if it sits on your
computer then that's when it goes crazy
you know but because i took it off i'm
telling you i never really had a problem
the limewire era was real
bear share
limewire i never uh i only was on
napster once
i didn't have a computer yet when
napster was popping i went to my
cousin's girlfriend's house and
downloaded
the big ljz freestyle oh yeah you gotta
have that it's funny because back then
like if you think about like the [ __ ]
like when like that [ __ ] was popping the
random [ __ ] you would download it'd be
like hella freestyle you would just type
in like a rapper you liked freestyle and
then you'd hit download and like it'd be
it'd either be fire or it would be
nothing that
the description would be wild it'd be a
radio rip right right it was crazy not
and i i think that's the beauty in it
because
i would find so much i was a big kanye
fan right so i would find all kanye's
[ __ ] like even to this day i could tell
peop i tell people yo you ever heard
this song they're like that's not me too
man like all the like like the whack
ends and i mean i remember when he did
the um
the original home
ended up being homecoming with the dude
from [ __ ] coldplay and i'm like this
song is like six years old and john
legend was on that one right yeah john
legend was on that giant scene the
original yeah
some of the freestyles he had yeah
the kind like the uh
was it the milkshake freestyle he did
with common
yeah there was some ill kanye [ __ ] yeah
because he was coming up at the time he
was still like on a come up and that was
his real i remember being on the
rockefeller website like listening to
snippets of
late registration and when you actually
heard the album the album was completely
different than the the snippets that
they were playing he had that one record
uh
where he was sampling a part of the
martin show
it was like we can't even sit and talk
without you oh man that [ __ ] like i
heard that oh my god
how old are you
i'm 29. oh yeah so i'm 35 so yeah i was
like a sophomore in high school my boy
was putting me on like kanye tapes and
this was like a year and a half or two
before a college dropout so we were like
so i had like i had a burnt cd with like
27 kanye songs on it that was random
like pre-college dropout yeah and then
my my best friend's brother ended up
touring with uh he's in a group called
dilated peoples
and so he toured
they opened up for kanye on the college
dropout tour
so i was like 14. i got a picture of
kanye when i was 14 and 15. that's crazy
he was wearing the ping pong
he was wearing a um
a shirt with uh
was it bill gates mug shot it was a
college dropout shirt but it had like
bill gates like in the 70s on it that's
crazy yeah it was dilated people's kanye
and i went to the album release show
i went to
that dilated people's album release show
in la which was a part of the college
dropout tour and he brought out
oh the young guns were on that tour too
young guns are on that tour
yeah that was wild i still have um
my merch from that show it was like a
blue college dropout sure you signed it
shout out to yay shout out to you the
greatest did you buy a stem player no
are you gonna buy one i don't even know
how to i just went on his website and
bought it he's going it's on the website
honestly i was talking about that the
other day i was like
stem player listen if i could help
anyone break the music industry from
raping artists i'm gonna do it and
especially if it's kanye here's 200
right right right
i just i hate the music industry and how
yo that's the predatory it is so if like
kanye can like break it
let's break it i'm with it that's a good
idea man i i was pondering somebody
asked me the other day like are you
gonna buy this template i said no
and then i instantly was like but why
not you know what i mean like i think
about it if someone told you
10 years ago
yo there's this exclusive album from
kanye west it's 200 bucks and you own it
forever and you get to break down the
stems on it
you'd be like
yeah
this is the only place i could hear this
did you say you get to break down the
stems on it yeah so you can play so
listen there's four
there's four stems so there's the it's
the vocals yeah the bass the beat so you
can like listen to it in in the in
whatever way you want like you could bro
it's [ __ ] crazy
that's why they call it a stem player
now it makes sense but that [ __ ] is
crazy
nah that's genius you could like turn up
like the yeah like you could set the
levels like it's pretty wild he did it
with uh the the first donda
wow right was the first donda
was that when he first did it
yeah i'm like yo [ __ ] this music
industry actual device yeah
it's like a [ __ ] company it looks
like a [ __ ] bluetooth speaker low-key
yeah i'm a cop i'm a cop
yeah so you could like you pretty much
update it so like
um
the version of donda2 is not even
mastered right now
but i guess mike dean has mixed and
mastered it so like the new version
you're gonna be able to like upload onto
your stem player because like right now
it's like super unfinished demos but
it's kind of cool that you could like
listen to the
the whole process yeah just plug your
[ __ ] in and update it he kind of did
that with pablo lowkey he was like
updating pablo while it was on spotify
right right right here you've been at
division you already had the vision yeah
i don't know was kanye like uh like
who's your
who was like very formative and like
forming your style your
kind of what you do it was a few people
was kanye was pharrell
it was jay-z i feel like it was jay-z
lyrically it was on kanye as far as like
the sound and the production
like pharrell i just always liked his
whole vibe in his production and like
his voice and everything and how he like
implemented different genres yeah yeah
and so i think those three is like they
were the biggest for me
pharrell's uh that guy man and he don't
age yeah it's kind of crazy
he still looks he still looks like he's
24 years old he said he um it's because
he washes his face with cold water you
know and he got laser removal on all his
tattoos usually that doesn't go well
he's for roto so
you know he's a legend i can't wait this
new pusha t album they're saying is half
produced by pharrell half well half
produced by the neptunes half produced
by yay
as well
wait wait where the [ __ ] is my clips
album it fell down and broke it's
supposed to be right there lord willing
is usually right there instead we have a
floating [ __ ] foot
shout out to odd socks um
so you uh
the new album
i feel like lyrics to go are we
considering those projects are kind of
more just like they feel
um those are like those are the projects
they're like things that i drop at the
beginning of the year to show people
like what i'm thinking what's on my mind
and how i'm going into
you know album mode was the album in
2020 your like real debut album the one
my debut album was in 2019 okay go down
photo
yeah the one in 2020 is the one that had
uh joey badass boss on their record that
[ __ ] was fire um
are you in album mode right now is this
yeah yeah i mean i would move for you
you just sold out a show in l.a 200
people yeah it's a pretty big deal yes
sir was that fonda um what what was the
venue um the vermont the vermont okay i
know where that is yeah that's gotta be
dope do you remember because like you
used to be managed by sean healy so i'm
sure you've done a bunch of random ass
shows
yeah yeah do you remember
like what's the most random [ __ ] you
opened the show for cause
i had to have been super random like
i don't even remember the guy's name
honestly well what about one that you do
remember that was just like what the
[ __ ] is going on here like i just opened
up for like
half of the yin yang twins or something
honestly i wish i had that kind of
experience bro like early on um i think
i mean it wasn't really random i opened
up felupe and i was that was a vibe
obviously that was crazy
um
yeah watching him perform was just crazy
uh
but
i
the only one i i i know i don't remember
the person's name but i i remember
that um
in order to even get like sean's
attention i
like this dude was doing a show he was
headlining the show i was like damn so
nobody's giving me my own headline in la
and that's where most of my fans were at
and this was years ago and so i was just
like yo i just opened for some random
whoever they got performing so i just
picked one it was like yo i opened for
him and you sold a hell of a time i sold
helen way more tickets than dude and i
ended up selling like 150 tickets and
that's pretty much yeah but the dude
only sold like probably like 50 or 70 or
something you sure you don't remember
who it is i don't i swear i don't i said
i don't know
like i don't want to throw him under the
bus he only sold 50 tickets it was papa
sparks but it was
it was it was crazy though and and like
that's when he hit me up and he was like
yo
yo i want you to come into the office
and he gave me a few more shows and we
sold all of those out we sold out in la
and then he even went back to new york
because he wasn't even doing shows in
new york anymore right and then we sold
out new york too and then he was like yo
i want to manage you and that's what
that's what um what do you think is
about what you do that like is i guess
crossed over to la so well because
that's kind of a to be from new york and
to have like a fan base like that in la
that early it's kind of a tough thing to
accomplish especially not doing i guess
traditional la music yeah
i don't know
i'm gonna be real like i really i can't
tell you um
like i didn't have no music videos
right like no real music videos
especially i didn't have videos in l.a
so to try to like act like i'm out there
but i guess it was just the way the
music resonated somehow it got over to
the west coast and
that's that's that yo we got to take a
break in the interview real quick tell
you about our folks at my bookie man
this is my favorite time of the year to
gamble i love gambling on sports and if
you've been thinking about putting your
toe into the pool come and join me at my
bookie okay right now we're doing a
promotion and my book is crazy when you
sign up for a new account and you make
your first deposit they will match that
deposit up to a thousand dollars it is
march madness the ncaa tournament is
here the brackets is getting filled out
what i need y'all to do also is go on to
my bookie when you sign up they got
their my bracket promotion going on it's
pretty crazy so essentially you sign up
for my bracket first place grand prize
winner gets a bitcoin a whole bitcoin
second place get some crazy ass nft
that's worth a [ __ ] ton of money i don't
know [ __ ] about nfts third place hundred
thousand dollars in cash and prizes so
what are you doing go to my bookie right
now man get in on some of this march
madness some of this nba action i wonder
what the odds were on tom brady coming
back from retirement sheesh
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g one word when you sign up
and your first deposit will be matched
up to a thousand dollars in free money
let's get back to the interview yo so
something that happened to you recently
that i feel like uh has happened to
someone who i'm close with actually one
of the artists that i manage um
is an ex of yours accused you of some
[ __ ] that you didn't do
uh i thought you addressed it very
transparently on your project in a dope
way
um
what is that like to go through
because it's it's almost in 2022
if a girl could accuses you of something
it's almost impossible
for you to defend yourself because when
it hits the internet
i feel like and i i mean obviously this
is just from what i've experienced and
seen
there's really nothing that the guy can
say
that is like
that can really like
i guess maybe sway people to not believe
the female if that makes sense and it
kind of puts us all in a really weird
world where like anyone can say anything
about you
and it's on you
to prove that it's [ __ ] what was
that like to go through man
oh it was terrible bro like it's um
it it brings you you go through a lot of
stuff mentally and i realize that people
really don't know what that's like you
know to be that popular and to be
going through something like that you
know
so
it is when you're in it is bad you know
it's bad for your mentals for your
psyche and you really have to like
you have to keep your mind you know you
have to keep your head and that's the
hardest part is like
keeping keeping your brain through all
the [ __ ] that's happening around you
and like
moving forward and not backward you know
so
yeah it was it like uh did you ever did
you feel helpless at all
hell yeah you know you feel it feels
like
it feels like damn this person that i
spent all this time with you know
a year and a half
you know it's like
you know everybody's been in a
relationship where
you have ups and you have downs right
and
but you have those really good times and
you share everything with this person
and you you know you're sitting down
watching stupid shows and all of this
stuff for this for so for somebody
to you know get angry one day
and try to ruin your life because so for
somebody else somebody to get angry at
you and then
because you don't you know want to be in
a relationship or because whatever
it's like and do that it's just like
it's it's mind-boggling you know yeah
it's crazy because kind of how you
describe the situation on your record
was kind of like very similar to what my
boy went through and
it's like it's just it can be defeating
man because like i said like it's just
like what the [ __ ] like i feel like
people should really there should be
some sort of law that gets passed or if
you do some [ __ ] like that
like you're going to jail for as long as
whatever the [ __ ] you accuse someone of
doing to you because you could literally
ruin someone's life
because people don't even think
about the context or well what if she's
full of [ __ ] that's the thing
they don't even think it don't matter
they already made their mind up yeah i
mean but it also just so it
but that's the thing too man one thing
that i asked for before that whole thing
happened was for like
more confidence and more like clarity of
mind and everything
and to really have control over myself
and my mind and like what's going on
and
that situation kind of forced me
to to be one with myself you know what i
mean
so like
it really all of this [ __ ] that's
happening is [ __ ] you know what i
mean social media this that third like
people are so it made me realize that
people are really like dumb you know
what i mean like they dumped but it's
not their fault you know
it's they're just flowing with the
algorithm they're going with their
design to do this you know what i mean
it's like this thing is designed to take
control of your mind
so like you believe whatever you see you
know
like it's like the the spider-man you
like spider-man of course of course so
you watch the new spider-man and the
other where it's just like the guy oh
you mystery the mysterious where he made
everyone believe yeah he's like they'll
believe anything nowadays they'll
believe anything and and the thing is
that's the thing about the internet it
doesn't they don't these people don't
know me you know these people have never
had a conversation with me uh
so it's just like you start to think how
could this person actually have an
opinion about me you know
and and even that incident aside just in
general yeah in general yeah it's like
and the stuff that people say on the
internet the like the cruel
crazy crazy and they would literally
never say it to your face so
you know what it is it kind of just like
put me in a place where i was forced
to like
step the [ __ ] up into
my manhood into like really the power of
my mind and just like and really so
every day
i capture that more you know what i mean
so yeah put you in that secret like
almost like like feast or famine type
mentality where it's like
because if you let it that [ __ ] could
just
knock you off your rocker and you never
recover because
you have people who probably never heard
your music don't know you for from [ __ ]
commenting about you trying to get you
canceled it's it's a wild it's
definitely a wild situation i can only
imagine to be in it did you notice
people
uh
start acting a little different i tell
you
everybody you know everybody
what
crazy and that's another battle you know
people around you acting different
people that know you acting different
you know people that know you you know
what i mean i like like close with you
not everybody obviously you have your
day ones that right right rock with you
and who know you and be like yo there's
some [ __ ] whatever
but
you know that's that's another battle
you know where you you have to even you
have to
get closer and closer to yourself you
have to accept certain things about
certain people and there's some people
that take advantage of the situation and
it's like oh now you're in this
situation oh now i'm gonna use it to do
this you know what i mean
it's like
it's a crazy it's a crazy situation to
be in but you know what like
when you keep your mind through some
[ __ ] like that
you end up way stronger you know what i
mean and your circle ends up way tighter
and the people that rock with you you
know they really [ __ ] with you you know
what i mean and you can like see like oh
i mean it almost kind of is like a
blessing in disguise in the sense that
like those people you're talking about
you know you they kind of expose
themselves in that in that time where
you could be like oh no i
when things got like this you behave
this way or you try to take advantage of
a certain type of situation and
you just cut them out that's what it is
and that's that's that's easy like that
you know you seem pretty uh
like we talked about earlier pretty
self-contained when it comes to the
creative process
um
like signing management like is like
like
obviously used to be managed by shawn
you said he doesn't manage you anymore
those are important decisions any artist
makes your independent um what about
management are you managed by anyone are
you
what do you got going on in that
i mean i ruined my i run my music life
more like a business you know my career
is more like a business than like me
being an artist you know
i'm kind of just
um
i'm i'm my own artist and i have a
business manager i have
you know um an accountant i have these
things do you like self i was gonna say
you feel like the kind of guy you could
just self-manage
yeah pretty much pretty much i have
people around me that like um have like
an assistant that you know takes my
emails and stuff like that but like
you're a good delegator yeah it runs
more like a business it runs more like a
business than like i'm an artist that
does a whole bunch of stuff like we even
decided we don't go we don't do tours
anymore we do um we we do one show
uh like per quarter you know so
that's that's what we're doing right now
because you know that's what we want to
do and that's you know i want to be home
with my family i want to be home my kid
whatever how does your son he's five
yeah that's an important age to be
around yeah so i'm i get to i get to be
around cause you could do like 30 dates
if you wanted to but it's like
and you're gone for 45 days that's a lot
you know you rather just
do the big ones yeah it's almost like
kind of like makes people
be like oh [ __ ] we gotta drive to la to
go to this [ __ ] and that's what i want
to do too like and i want to i want to
actually turn it into a festival like
that happens four times a year in the
states and then we go to europe and do a
couple days there so and i wanted to be
outdoors soon so that's why we did la in
the winter so um next time we come to la
we might be doing 5 000
in some outdoor venue turn it into 10
000. yeah yeah keep going that's so
that's that's really the plan so we kind
of want to stray away from doing things
the way everybody else is doing them and
just do things the way we because that's
always been my career it's just like how
do you how do i want to do it not what
everybody else is doing you know i'm
assuming you've had a lot of people try
to sign you
um what has been the closest you've been
assigning to a major situation um
not close at all you know not close at
all i don't think i've ever
seriously considered it yeah and i've
never seriously considered it like i
think somebody offered me something and
i definitely i completely just like
they offered me something so ridiculous
that i just sent them back something
even more ridiculous and that like the
deal was like so bad it was so bad the
deal was so bad that i felt like i was
insulted i just sent something
crazy or the other way like here's the
counter i mean
i need 25 million dollars
100 of my masters for one album i think
i asked for like i think i asked for
like a million
500 000
non-recoupable like oh yeah
like some crazy come some crazy like i
have control over all my albums and i
was like oh yeah by the way um only one
album you only get one hour yo it's
rough because like you'll talk to some
of these like record people especially
like
i won't call them like majors but like
in between major guys
and they'll tell you like
like they'll talk to you and they'll
like tell you exactly what you want to
hear
and he'd be like oh [ __ ]
yeah that felt good and then the [ __ ]
contract gets sent over and it's always
some [ __ ] [ __ ] like every single
time like it's like you gotta almost
like if you're like an artist and you
kind of wanna
kind of be in your space and like you
just got to find a dope distro partner
and turn up yeah i said the thing is
with me i i never really wanted to be
rich off this stuff you know what i mean
so it was like
the minute that i saw 8 000 in my
account from rap i was like oh [ __ ] all
that other [ __ ] you know what i mean so
like
signing was never a problem in a month
was that a monthly check nah that was
that was just like i just saw eight
thousand in my account
it was a lot for somebody who never made
it show kid or tunecore or something um
and um yeah so as soon as i saw that i
was like yeah we gonna we we can do this
let's just keep on creating content so
we could keep the streams going so we
could so ever since then it was being
run like a business it was like yo how
much if we make five thousand this month
how can we make ten thousand next month
if you make you know this then how can
we make twenty thousand and
like we just worked it like that and
it worked out so what's been um
so far your best month off of music for
inspirational purposes because you're
independent a lot of a lot of kids don't
understand like you know
they're going to jump at the first big
bag someone tries to drop in
on their laps and it's going to be a
shitty split and it's going to be
money they're going to have to live off
of because they're never going to recoup
give us some inspiration what's been
your best month man
i can't i can't do that i can't say that
give us like a ballpark nah i can't i
can't do that that's personal you know
you're the face no no i mean
i can't say that bro i can't say that
that's fair that's fair you're doing
well though
i mean i don't got to work i don't got
to work at nine to five so i'm good i
feel like anybody if you're a musician
if you can get to the point where you
could just pay your bills and live like
cool you [ __ ] won you won you weren't
i i i say that 100 i felt like that for
years you know no matter how much money
i was making i get i i get to feed my
kid comfortably and put a roof over my
head
i always felt like i won so it's just
like i don't feel like i just started
winning i feel like i've been winning
you know what made you um have a
just you know
do the la and the new york thing you got
a spot in both cities
obviously la's kind of a hub where you
really i mean a lot of artists gonna end
up end up out here to try to make it why
why kind of split time between both
cities it's the weather for me you know
it's the weather
um i got a spot by the beach you know
it's like
really non like music industry related
reasons not music because most people
are like man you know i got i got to be
on la man you know i got to be there to
go to meetings and do pr or whatever the
[ __ ] bro i came out here to retire you
feel me like that's why i got a crib out
here you might like florida a little bit
more angle no no no no no i could never
go i could never move to florida i love
the west coast florida's fire though
florida is fire for the vacation i love
my yeah okay bro miami honestly my
favorite place to visit ever
she was lit you know miami is amazing
it's it's amazing thing about miami
that's incredible is no one's ugly i
always say like when you go to miami
everybody is beautiful if you go to
mcdonald's
the lady in the drive-through is a
[ __ ]
she could she could start her only fans
tomorrow and make six figures
like everyone is [ __ ] fine in miami
it's like
there's no one ugly it's just the most
beautiful people in the world that's
true and they're all there it's like
it's just beautiful people making more
beautiful people
yeah shout out to miami i love it there
yeah it's a wild place though well
florida's like um
it should be its own country low-key
because it kind of is
there's like miami and i lived in
florida for a few years so
i lived in tampa though tampa was a
nice but
country champion was lit though i went
to tampa it was fire no tampa's dope
it's just like his own thing it's not
miami it's his own thing it's like yeah
it's true that that's true like that's
true it's his own thing it's like white
trash miami
yeah i didn't get that vibe
no it's there that's there it's
somewhere i don't know the place where i
was at that [ __ ] was turned you probably
performed in ebor city i don't even
remember it yeah you probably from
university um
the new album do you have any sort of
plot for the date is the date set have
you turned it in
i haven't turned it in but um we're
looking at like middle of june you know
okay summertime what features you got
man features anybody i'll be real all
right
my the features um brianna castro she's
from philly
she's a singer really dope
um
my boy hello o'shea from brooklyn new
york city
um we got my boy sam
and he's from
he's from new york i don't think he's
from brooklyn or new york or the city
but i think he's from like new york
state um who else
those those three
that's it
oh yeah and i got a recording session
with my home girl daveon
she was on um the dreamville album
and yeah those are the those are the
only features i got so far
dude did you think about who was talking
about him
futuristic
was it futuristic
i don't know we're talking about you
i think i think i've talked about you
twice in the last like month on the
podcast
you popped up i was like oh this guy's
in [ __ ] l.a right now this game got
to get him on the show man
yeah
um
anything else like you obviously talk
about running [ __ ] like a business
obviously you got the merch the gear
is there anything else that you are
working on outside of just
recording music that is that is you know
important to you right now well right
now i mean obviously being a great
father yeah i'm planning on um i'm
planning on starting my own label on my
own company where we you know distribute
music and
help people grow
and um
we're able to really build marketing
plans around artists and like you know
figure out new [ __ ] in this new
landscape or whatever's going on because
i want to see people win you know so um
i want to create
i want to create that for some people do
you feel like you could see yourself
managing artists
even if you're not signing them like
could could you manage an artist you
think
i could definitely manage artists but i
feel like i could do anything you know
that's fair
um so yeah i definitely feel like i
could oh if i was managing an artist
they [ __ ] blow you know because like
because and i'm very confident in that
you know
yeah and you're not going to work on
nobody is who in it
who is um who's been kind of like the
biggest
artist that's kind of reached out to you
maybe not someone you've necessarily
worked with but someone who has noticed
what you're doing or
maybe like the post or
you found out is [ __ ] with what you
got going on
um
i'm not sure
like
i feel like a lot of a lot of big
artists have reached out at some point
um
i mean doing the doing the feature with
joey was a big deal you know that's a
super big deal that was that was a
really big deal it was like we both from
brooklyn like we even got we our roots
kind of like come from the same place
and that we like we're moving in the
same circles when we were younger you
know
so um not being able to being able to
work with joey was was dope you know
yeah did anyone you know what's crazy
because like when i first heard you i
was like man i could see
someone like tde or dreamville trying to
come in and like
you kind of fit like any any interest
from either of those two camps ever in
in in what you got going on no no uh i
just always been a lone wolf you know a
lone wolf moving yeah that's it that's
hey man it's it's working out
do you feel like for you to kind of like
you not that you would even care but for
you to kind of
commercially reach your fullest
potential
that you might have to compromise in the
future and
end up working with a bigger
platform or a bigger label or do you are
you just like comfortable that'll come
um
i don't
i i don't necessarily i'm not waiting
for that you know um
i feel like sometimes i think about it
and i'm like damn i might actually if i
wanted to make it there i would i think
about the fact that i might actually
have to like compromise
my [ __ ] or compromise like my idea or
assign to a label or whatever like that
thought those thoughts have come to my
mind because i see like the success of
like something i think russ did a good
job
of
taking all the uh equity and leverage he
built up sort of like what you do right
and kind of doing like a little
partnership with colombia and i think he
only dropped two albums and he was out
now he killed that [ __ ] like he ran it
up
put him on a different level and now
he's back dropping on tunecore every
week oh yeah he i think he did it he did
it the best where it's just like
everything worked out for him you know
yeah where
he did it the way he wanted to do it on
his terms he got out of it on his terms
and he's still chilling and i feel like
a part of it is because he's just so
low-key about it you know he he just
drops his music he has a [ __ ] ton of
music you know so much do you think
that's important for an independent
artist to stay
very consistent in running up the
catalog even though because i think
sometimes we like artists overthink
putting [ __ ] out sometimes i'm sure
you've you've crossed that bridge as an
artist where you're like you're sitting
on something
it might have been fire but nine months
later you're like i'm over this [ __ ] and
it never comes out i never felt i never
had that i never had to happen you're a
[ __ ] alien then no it's not because i
think i think independent artists do
work differently in that in that way
whereas like
um when you're independent artists gain
some success
like you're always dropping you know
what i mean like yeah you're always
dropping because you got to stay
relevant and i feel like as an indie
you don't the only way you stay relevant
is either like you keep dropping records
or you're doing something else that's
keeping you relevant in the music space
non-stop yeah but you have to you have
to stay in front of people you can keep
putting shots up right right yeah and if
the shots don't make it it's not as big
of a deal as if you're on a major right
because if you drop an album and it
flops on a major who gives a [ __ ] or no
there is a big there's a lot of money
behind it but if you're independent you
just move on and put something else out
exactly you don't have to you there's no
embarrassment you know there's no like
oh this didn't work out for me it's like
nah just do that [ __ ] again you know
there's nobody saying like this this is
less pressure because if you put out a
record that doesn't do so well
only you're the only one that's going to
be disappointed you don't have label
people that are like them like maybe
he's not selling like he used to or
maybe everybody's doubting you now when
now the pressure's on you to be like
damn like and and maybe i got to put up
make music like this or maybe i got to
change my style and then you start
questioning yourself so like being indie
is just like bro i dropped this record
it didn't do that well then get on new
music friday whatever
i'ma drop another one and maybe this one
will and that really was how my career
went it's just like yo with every week
every other week you know so um how do
you want to be remembered when it's all
said and done man like what do you want
your legacy to be
um
i just want to be remembered
as somebody some dude that says some
real [ __ ] on the record you know it's
like
um i got on i i got on
into this music [ __ ] and i said what was
on my mind
and i helped people
navigate life and
like
that's it and i was you know i was a
part of that journey and a part of it
like personal growth and emotional
growth that's it yo we got to stop the
interview real quick shout out to our
presenting sponsor odd socks baby hey
man listen all i keep on my ass is odd
socks draws all i keep on my feet are
socks you know why because they are the
most comfortable socks in the world and
i'm not just saying this because they
promote the podcast i'm telling you the
socks are crazy uh they got all the
licenses look they got halloween socks
they have back to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxoficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane in [ __ ] sane
uh go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev that's one word
together bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssoxofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview we're
talking about kanye earlier
what is
the best kanye west album um
got this dropout
college dropout
your fa is that your favorite or is that
the best that's the best for me yeah so
it's your favorite it's best the best in
my favorite yeah yeah i kind of i kind
of have like a so my to me the best is
my beautiful dark choice of fantasy but
my my favorites late registration okay
all right why is the difference between
your best and
um you know i think people can
i think we could do that and [ __ ] like
when we think of the basketball players
like you can acknowledge that like
michael jordan might be better than kobe
bryant but there's a lot of people who's
like but kobe is my guy
to me late registration was just like a
moment in my life that i like vividly
remember and
but my beautiful dark twisted fantasy is
like
a perfect album
it don't get much better than that right
right
that's that's true college dropout like
i listen back and like never let you
down still one of my favorite songs ever
obviously two words but like
breathe in breathe out i was like yeah
there's a couple of those records that
like
like the the workout record was like
didn't age well it didn't age real but
that [ __ ] was fired yeah when it when it
was when it came out
it was amazing but i think of like
i don't i think late registration aged
gracefully it did
college dropout college job i had 21
songs on it it was deep
it was it was it was a lot you know it
was a lot like college dropout
i dropped the album called photo that
had 19 songs on it and i think the only
reason i did that was because kanye
dropped a 21-track album like
he was the only person i knew that had
that many songs at our album at that
time you know i think drake had like he
he puts like that many songs on now he
does yeah drake's a lot yeah now kanye
uh
i remember how big of a deal it was that
he
put freeway and most dev on the same
song and people thought that was so wild
and like in retrospect it's like was it
that wild nah but he was doing great he
had everybody on that album there was
just a perceived like wall between like
commercial rap and like
raucous records i guess the boom bap
[ __ ]
and he like broke down the wall and was
like the bridge he put it yo he got
jay-z most death consequence geos like
all these dudes on the same and i think
that's ludicrous ludacris lulu chris was
on it like twister jamie
yo everybody was on that album so i'm
like and and honestly i gotta give it to
kanye because he gave when i'm working
on an album
i i think i try to think like that
what's gonna make this record good
what's gonna make this record fire
instead of like who's the biggest artist
or who's the biggest name it's like yo
who needs to be on this [ __ ] so this
[ __ ] sounds like crazy and ev it doesn't
have to sound exactly like you know
exactly what everybody you know oh you
gotta he's not trying to fit a sound
he's trying to create a sound and so he
gets artists over these beats that it's
just like yo you may not spit over this
particular type of beat but like it's
gonna sound good trust me and that's
what the producer does so like as far as
like like as far as production and
learning how to produce a record and and
put all of the pieces together properly
i i try to emulate kanye you know
because he can he can do that [ __ ] he's
not just throwing people on that's true
what's his
worst album
worst album
um 808's
worse than jesus's king huh oh i didn't
even listen to jesus it's terrible damn
i wouldn't even know you know what
though shout out to books there's some
amazing beats on there jesus king has
some incredible production but it was it
was terrible yeah it was the most
disappointing
it was kind of like
jordan's wizards career you know like we
just try to forget about it you know
like jesus is king like yeah i mean he
won a grammy for best gospel album
wow that's crazy for best guys whatever
yeah jesus is king got the grammy i kind
of like kanye in his current
vibe it feels very like
2009 2010 yay he's out here [ __ ] he's
running around and all black
no
he's living his life he's had three
[ __ ] in the last
90 days he's just trading them out it's
like this is like demon kanye like i'm
just well i wish the vmas were still a
thing because i feel like kanye would
would storm the vmas right now honestly
i just wish the best for kanye me too me
too but i just love i'm just like yo the
music is i'm just like yeah i feel like
he's finally cause you know i feel like
connie really hasn't cared about music
like
like we probably wanted him to in a
while because he's been
becoming a billionaire
and dealing with what happens when you
become a billionaire but i feel like
he's like very much in his like
bag right now so it's exciting um
outside of yay albums what's your
favorite album of all time
lauren hill miss education hey man shout
out to miss lauren
yeah that's that's that's one of them
once
it's the best album you know you ever
see lauren live
i did one time were you disappointed
i was i was disappointed but not because
she didn't sound good she was late i
wasn't disappointed at that
i almost expected yeah yeah right i was
disappointed at the fact that she didn't
perform any of the songs like they were
on the record oh my god i know i just
killed me three times oh man never you
never heard every single time she
performs it's like she's doing some like
wild ass jam rock
session version i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on up there
by the way lauryn hill is one of the
greatest of all time
but i hope one like
one day she'll do like a tour
maybe it's like the 30-year anniversary
maybe and she like just does
the records or
the unplugged version of the wreck
because the unplugged album was so
[ __ ] incredible damn
like
but lauren hill is just fired you know
that's why i think that's why it's so
sad that she don't perform the songs
like the way they are on the record
because it's like the people love that
album like people love those albums like
the unplugged whole generation of
people probably will never see her
perform that [ __ ] the way
yeah it's crazy what about uh actually i
never you know they did the score uh
they did a fuji's reunion tour i don't
know how that went i don't know if it
went well because i didn't hear much
about it um what's the
weirdest [ __ ] not weirdest but what's
the most like random non-hip-hop [ __ ]
you're listening to like on a regular
basis random
no i don't really listen to it a lot
right now uh i just discovered tame
impala high on shrooms that [ __ ] was
wild have you heard of tammy paula yeah
yeah i heard him saying that [ __ ] is
crazy
it's like made for you to listen to it
if you're on psychedelics
i wouldn't know
never done any psychedelics i've done
psychedelics i've just never really
listened to anything while doing it i
just found a playlist and it was like
shroom playlist on spotify like 8 000
followers i was a [ __ ] play on that
[ __ ] in a hot tub and just
and you were in a hot summer that [ __ ]
must have been hey and shout out to don
demarco don demarco's got some wild ass
songs for [ __ ] tripping hard like did
you ever you know that guy is demarco
you mean mac demarco mac demarco that's
his name that dude's [ __ ] yeah he's
ill he's uh his videos are wild he's a
well dude yeah he's a well dude also mac
miller was on that playlist a lot mac
miller's got great i never even put it
together i was like oh [ __ ] it hits
different bro when you're tripping like
gorillas listen to the gorillas while
you're tripping the gorillas yeah listen
to gorillas
that's your that's your uh
if you're on shrooms well i've never
really listened to anything while on
like a psychedelic but like i usually
get high
i smoke weed and listen to like a lot of
gorillas like my favorite song is on
melancholia you play that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
will take you somewhere else man for
real chance of the gorillas the gorillas
were the first nfts
what
they thought about it
think about it
i mean yeah they were they were 2d they
were 2d they were like nfts little kids
you know because they got theirs
there's this uh asian uh what's the
asian cartoon band
there's like a band that toured they
came here and they sold out like 2 000
people
but they're
it's it's like a band
but they're
like virtual
characters
and they're [ __ ] huge
and i'm like well that's just the
gorillas but like they're like it's like
meta it's like a metaverse band
and they're [ __ ] lit
yo did you ever see the um the gorillas
um
cribs episode i remember it yeah i i
vaguely remember it yeah that's that was
like an nft because it's like it was a
complete
like animation of them doing a cribs
episode
you know that was anything about it i
think the most all right bro it was like
they liked the first nfts yeah they
brought i mean yeah they had a whole
online think about it
nowadays you could be super talented but
maybe you don't have the confidence to
be in front of the camera or
and you could just [ __ ] create like a
persona online and animate it and like
put out music and no one ever will know
who the [ __ ] you are
is what it sound to be a love bro it's a
good time no excuse yeah you could be
700 pounds at home not able to get out
of a chair and if you got a great voice
you know [ __ ] have someone create
some sort of uh
do you do the nfc thing yeah i don't i
have um i have a crypto mori
is that a big deal
yeah yeah a crypto mori it's it's a
community you know you've out of it's
like you own nft you're part of a
community and that's what everyone says
is to go to prison it's about some [ __ ]
what that's crazy yeah
i wasn't expecting all these [ __ ]
artists are going to like getting
investigated and [ __ ]
for [ __ ]
nft they call them like pool rug scams
uh someone in the nba what's the nba
player that's about to
who is it darren fox from the kings
this is a good player very rich got a
five-year extension this guy's paid he's
like he might go to jail over the [ __ ]
over the nft [ __ ] yeah it's like it's
like it's kind of like some pump and
dumb [ __ ] right
my team don't do that a bunch of people
um a bunch of people are under
investigation hella artists
hella artists the guys you would be like
oh yeah i could see that
i'm trying to think who who you would
tell you probably [ __ ] this guy knows
everything
just tell the name you're not a [ __ ]
camera bro you shot somebody this past
summer
he's from canada
someone shot someone from
tory lanez is he he might get in trouble
allegedly he shot someone again
i have i mean listen that that might be
a similar situation where
everyone rushed to be like [ __ ] you tory
lanez
and maybe it didn't happen that way
that's all i'm gonna say
because i've heard some
sources close to the situation and
we'll see how it plays out but that's
kind of us we were talking about that
earlier
i mean we don't know what happened right
obviously i was i wasn't there it very
well could have happened the way that
but
if it didn't damn [ __ ] really
x'ed him all the way out
before seeing what actually happened
right um so you um are you the nft
community you're a part of is this like
a
uh do you just buy them like are you
buying art or are you like
you're like this is my gang i don't know
how this [ __ ] works bro yeah i bought a
i would artwork um i bought a yes it's
like you buy one of the artworks and
it's just like what i realized man is
that um
like on twitter
i used to look at twitter like it was
this very toxic like thing but
in this community it's not like it's on
twitter like nfts is like on twitter
heavy but it's the only space where it's
just like everyone's nice yeah
everyone's cool as [ __ ] you know when
you say community
do you like put an oculus on and see all
these people huh and like like like
is this like in the metaverse like you
put oculus on and you like see the
homies who eat like help me understand
i'm gonna be real i own bitcoin i own
ethereum
i'm very surface level crypto i bought
ripple in 2017 you know like
but this whole nft [ __ ] i just feel like
there's so much
cartoon animals going on i don't know to
buy the rhino the ape the [ __ ]
the blinged out monkey i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on
why would you do any of that [ __ ] like
why would you buy anything and i feel
like there's so many like i saw like a
[ __ ] shark line there's everyone's
got a [ __ ]
cartoon animal
all i can do is tell you why you know
crypto mori i would [ __ ] with it so what
is that what is crypto more is it is it
a is that is it like maury povich a
bunch of different versions of maury
nah it's just they're like these little
dead guys right so like
like maury povich
he's kind of dead right
i mean maury's been like
maury's been hanging on
but like if maury died tomorrow you
wouldn't be surprised you'd be like yeah
it seems like his time i
nah but the real reason is just like yo
it's like can we let me pull these
things up hold on
how do i spell this [ __ ] c-r-y-p-t-o
okay i notice about crypto i'm not a
phone
i'm not a [ __ ] idiot i do own
something
crypto m
m-o-r-i-e-s
crypto maurice yeah more ease not more
not mori like mori povich it would have
been so much cooler if you would have
said yeah bunch of little cartoon maury
povich should we start that
kryptomoris
oh what about crypto steve wilkos
this is it right yeah that's it that's
it
wow
ten thousand skeleton dudes to remind
you to live your life fully
they've been randomly generated okay so
you have to buy these with ethereum
right yeah
do you have an oculus
no i don't but i've been thinking about
getting one
i feel like you should get one because
you own nfts and i feel like you could
like build a house and like walk around
i was thinking about getting some stuff
in the metaverse actually bro why not i
mean listen i'm gonna tell you this the
porn is wild
pretty crazy the porn the porn you put
the oculus on the oculus port is [ __ ]
lit bro
it's pretty crazy i i i've never
experienced it
um
you should try it
not even like
on some creep [ __ ] like
like you should just give it a shot like
just throw it on but oh [ __ ]
we put it on blueface and put a porno on
and he looked down and he was like oh my
god look at my white dick
it was pretty funny
i'm weak it is kind of racist though i
noticed like none of the
oculus porn has
dicks of color and like
it
seriously because like the whole idea is
that it's you right that's like doing
everything so you're like looking down
on the chick sucking your dick but it's
a white dick almost every time i would
venture to say i have only seen white
dicks on there that's crazy but the porn
industry in general very very racist
industry
it's probably the single
industry left that's like hasn't been
fully like
hit by cancel culture all the way
how can you cancel it exactly you know
it's like yeah we're racists big black
[ __ ] volume seven
asian hotties 79
like that's the only place that that
[ __ ] still flies you could not none of
that [ __ ] is flying because it's built
on like
like [ __ ] that is not you know
normal yeah did you start to the crypto
morris thing was that like did they like
were you approached to do that or are
you just passionate about the space
because there's some people are very
passionate about
crypto and nfts yeah i was super
interested and um i decided to
like i asked my friend um my friend drew
i was like yo what what kind of like
what should i be messing with you know
and he put me onto a few different
projects
and i saw a crypto morris i was like oh
that's fire you know and so i just
decided to invest in it
and that's it so have you made uh have
you made some bucks off of it i'm down
here checking them out
i'm not sure ethereum goes up and down i
think um
it's bruh i don't know i don't know much
about how you know it goes up in price
or
down in price
all right like i said all i really know
about is that like it's this really dope
community of people that kind of like
share each other's [ __ ] and like
i feel like i feel like you're reading
off of the crypto morris pamphlet right
now i'm not bro i'm not i'm just like
everyone's so nice it's a great
community yo i'm dead i'm dead ass man
like i think
man when you when you go through some
like deep [ __ ] you know with some some
darkness it's nice to see something
positive people around you you know
right so like yo community is like one
is
like the biggest thing about in life do
you have a discord for your fans yeah i
do i do because i'm gonna start using it
more like when i'm when i finish with
the album i'm gonna get on like discord
heavy because you get to like talk
directly with your people
would you do a nft album or a single or
anything and that's i don't think so i
don't think i want to like mix the
actual music with um
with nfcs
um i
i would do something like artistic with
nfts but like as far as like my music i
just like to have that like its own
thing you know
what is uh if you're not
making music you're not being a father
what are the television shows you binge
watch
if any
i watch movies
you know no tv shows i'm not really a tv
show didn't watch your favorite you know
i've been watching um abbott's
elementary no idea
it's like this thing on like it's this
new show on abc um
quinta
is a is the like the star of it you
didn't watch it for you you four you
know i did not watch before you're like
one of the only like nine people in the
world who weren't watching you for you
this week i guess that's me i wasn't
watching it's a show about kids
in high school [ __ ] and doing
fentanyl that's really all you need for
yourself
i saw season one but i mean so you saw
season one yeah yeah yeah i mean season
two is [ __ ]
pretty crazy yeah i don't i think season
one was enough for me right it's dark
yeah it's hella dark it's hella dark and
it's just like there's no way out it
gets worse
because the dude's dad
starts like yeah it's just great you
know the dude's dad was like it's it's
[ __ ] crazy i don't know what the
dude's dad was doing you don't remember
i don't know how he could get worse than
euphoria it does do you think do you
think season one of which one you think
is worse one or two as far as just the
level of [ __ ] crazy
season two right
there's a lot of dicks in season two
though i think that's dangerous bro like
you see how the world do you see how
kids are nowadays tons of dicks in
season two
every episode there's a day oh for sure
what's the [ __ ] shout out to zendaya she
wrote them in there isn't it crazy that
anybody can turn on the tv and watch
that [ __ ] like no that's that's actually
not true you need to have hbo max no
yeah
anyone with 9.99 all right but i'm
saying your 10 year old kid could throw
in your hb oh max and watch that 100
it's crazy that's nice my son is
and
my kid is like a pretty mature kid he's
a good kid gets straight a's but i've
never like hid no [ __ ] from him so like
he's also got an interesting
mother in his life
uh so i let him watch it for you
probably not the best move but
i think i don't know i mean he was going
to watch it anyway it's real i mean at
the end of the day like it's out there
you know you just got to kind of just be
able to like you know explain what the
[ __ ] is happening and it doesn't to me
it doesn't really glorify drugs as much
as it's like
yeah like zendaya is [ __ ] up in that
show rue is like she's like
there's like one episode in season two
that's
[ __ ] insane
did you ever watch curb your enthusiasm
yeah yeah
do you what's your favorite in your
opinion what's the greatest comedy ever
because i just got to an argument with
my boy about curb i said curb's just the
goat to me
comedy like just like sitcom comedy
there's curb there's the boondocks
there's [ __ ] martin there's yeah
that's all right boondocks was hilarious
um martin was hilarious you know what's
crazy is i still re-watch boondocks
episodes some of them are timeless but
so many of them were very like time
specific for like when they dropped
that they don't hit
that's like some of the chapelle skits
don't hit like they read in my mind bro
you read them yeah like the chappelle
[ __ ] like i i when they put i put on
netflix i rewatched all of it
uh and i was like damn some of this [ __ ]
like the mitsubishi commercial where the
girls dancing and he was like come on
titty like that you had to be around to
know what that commercial was that he
was like spoofing like chappelle was
hilarious now chappelle was like my
favorite like me and my cousins used to
sit around and laugh at that [ __ ] for
hours i think the clayton bixby skit is
probably the best skit ever it took it
it took it
it was so crazy bro that's just wild to
think that he got that [ __ ] off that
[ __ ] would have never flown in 2022. i
don't know but no nothing that he did
would float like he would go like
nothing
hey and back then he had joe rogan on
there he said he said i don't know if
you know this joe rogan but i smoke
rocks
he was walking across the coals his feet
were on fire this [ __ ] was amazing
hey so new album coming out in june yes
uh
you got the project the lyrics to goes
out the new the latest lyrics to go is
[ __ ] crazy um
i'm assuming you got other [ __ ] i mean
go buy a crypto mori
it's not a scam
we're not going to see you on the
headlines of [ __ ] hollywood unlocked
saying go to the friend under
investigation for nft rug pool crypto
more is legit boys
it's legit you should pitch to the
community the maury povich idea
i you know i'll talk to them about it
and see what they say i'm telling you
right i might i can't do anything you
know i mean i might buy a cartoon
version of maury povich
if there's like 58 different mori's
there's like you're the dad you're not
the dad maury there's like zombie mori
there's
morion fentanyl there's maury
happy maury they're sad maury
mori with the glasses reading maury so
you know how nnfts work then you know
how it works i mean i just looked at the
crypto morty's website it just kept
flashing like do you own crypto maurice
we have the owner here no this is
nothing no no you crazy oh the way i
said oh he owns a crypto more really the
way he was like yeah it's my [ __ ] why do
you think i know everything over here
i'm like now i know why you're talking
about it like you're reading off of a
[ __ ] pamphlet the owner's right here
well look man go shout out to my guy go
to the friend go follow him go stream
his music go support the merch
uh is this i mean your sh i mean this is
your [ __ ] yeah this is my [ __ ] flight
boys since 2008 you know
yeah supreme ever hit you with a
seasoned assist on that
no no not yet
they never will you don't think so no
yeah [ __ ] them
they got the same they use the same
thing as a life they like you they use
the same phone yo a life was so fire
yeah
i used to have a life tennis shoes yeah
them sisters fire and they actually look
like tennis balls right hey i had a bun
like four pairs of a-lice i had a red
pair of purple pair and these two are
the illest [ __ ] collabs of rappers
i want to say they did like some dip set
[ __ ] a life camera on [ __ ] no it's
cameron i still got that [ __ ] shirt
shout out to a life but yo shout out to
you go to the friend appreciate you
pulling up thank you podcast boom
fire